welcome back
um this is an additional section
um in this chapter
um that's based on some new material in
the in the second edition of the book
and it's called matrix completion and
and missing values
it's often the case that data matrices x
have missing entries which are often
represented by
n a
not available so this is a nuisance
since many of our modeling procedures
especially multivariate procedures such
as linear regression and glms require
complete data
as do principal components
however sometimes imputation is the
prediction problem
and we're going to see that in the next
example in what's known as recommender
systems
so one simple approach when you've got
missing data is mean imputation so you
replace the missing entries for a
variable by the mean of the non-missing
entries
so if x is a matrix that means in each
column which represents say a variable
you replace all the missing entries
by the mean of the non-missing entries
in that column
however this ignores the correlations
amongst the variables
we should be able to exploit the
correlations when imputing missing
values and clearly if you just use the
mean in for each variable you're
ignoring the the correlations
we also need to assume that the missing
values are missing at random either
missingness
should not be informative
so we're going to present an approach
that's based on principal components for
imputing missing values
just tell you a little bit about
recommender systems
so what we have here is part of a
spreadsheet
which shows customers who rented movies
from the netflix movie rental company
and along the top we see names of movies
you can see jerry maguire oceans road to
petition and so on
and
most of the matrix are little gray dots
which means that customer didn't see
that movie
but the places where their numbers
the customer was asked to rate the movie
after they saw it
with a rating between one and five i
mean i think one was the worst and five
was best right five was yes right and
with other numbers in between
and so you can see there's a few threes
and
fours and ones and fives right
so a very small fraction in this data
set they were actually this was a data
set that was put out there for a
competition
and it actually was one of the the stuff
it was really the start of these online
uh competitions prediction competitions
and the data set had 400 000 users
so we only show nine customers here
and
18
over 18 000 movies so it's a massive
matrix but only two percent of the
matrix had numbers in it and the rest
were missing well that competition was
around 2005 trevor right yeah yeah and
it was a first one million dollar first
prize for the first team that could get
could improve upon the existing system
by by at least 10 percent yeah
and it caused a huge excitement in the
machine learning and statistics
communities as i recall we won that
right
now
well actually
we did we didn't go into it thinking we
might win but after a few months we
realized this was really hard that the
data was so big it was just harder to
to get anywhere with it we got i think
we got down to maybe
close to what the current system was but
we didn't get anywhere near the exact
finish line
yeah so
the thing was netflix themselves had a
recommender system
and uh and the goal of the competition
was to make predictions for movies that
people hadn't seen what their rating
would be
and they the the
the winning team was the first to beat
the the netflix
recommend the system by 10 in root mean
squared error it took about three years
for someone to win three years
and there were approximately 40 000
teams all over the world submitting
entries to this competition
and the methods that were used were very
there's a huge variety but the method
we're about to show you is actually the
basis of
a lot of the systems use the method
we're going to show you right now as its
first step exactly
so that's why the method we're going to
show you is is one of the important
techniques out there and it's worth
knowing about
okay so let's get into the details
and
the idea is
we're going to use the principal
component model to do the imputation
in section 12.2.2 of the book
we have an interpretation of principal
components in terms of matrix
approximation
you see there that we've got a sum over
the rows and the columns
and we have the the difference between
each entry x i j
and then
an internal sum over the number of
components so here we're using we're
going to use m principal components
of a product of terms a i m b j m
may look rather technical
because it is
and
these ais and bj's are elements of a
matrix so we have a matrix a
which is going to be n by m n being the
number of rows
and we have a matrix b which is p by m
which
p being the number of columns or
variables
and these are the entry individual
entries of those matrices
and what this is basically saying is
that we're going to approximate the
matrix x by the product of these two
matrices and this is shown element by
element and we want to
minimize this over a and b
okay so this this is a
another interpretation of principal
components because it can be shown that
for any value m
the first m principal components provide
a solution for a
so these these are the principal
component scores
the z's
and for the b's
it's a principal component loadings
so principal components gives a solution
to this problem
now we say provides a solution
because i think it should be evident
that i can
alter the solution by multiplying all
the a's
by some number let's say s
say bigger than one
and divide all the b's by the same
number and i'll get the same solution
right so there's some arbitrariness here
multiplicative arbitrariness but
the principal components is one such
solution
okay
so that's just an interpretation of
principal components as a matrix
approximation best matrix approximation
the terminologies of rank m okay
but what do we do if the matrix is
missing elements well this is where the
technique arises for imputing missing
values
so what we do is it impose instead a
modified version of this approximation
criterion the outside looks the same we
want an a and a b
but now of course
some of the x ijs are missing so what we
do is we just sum the sum of squares
over the ij pairs that are observed and
we've got this little symbol script o
which is a set of all observed pairs of
indices i j
which is a subset of
of the possible all the possible n times
p
pairs so we still got the sum of squares
but of course only over the elements
that we observed
but importantly the a and b are still
these full matrices
so once we solve this problem
we've got a solution we can estimate a
missing observation x i j
using
the same sum
that we had before element y sum for the
pair x i j but now putting in the
estimates for a and b so it seems simple
we can also in doing this we not only
impute the missing values but we can
approximately recover the m principal
component
scores and loadings as if the data were
complete
so rob it's both a method for computing
principal components when you've got
missing values
and for imputing the missing values in
the matrix now you mentioned the
beginning that using mean imputation is
maybe a good start but it doesn't
exploit correlations how does this
somehow
capture correlations well i think robert
captures correlations in the same way as
principal components do
so principal components
you know exploit the correlations when
finding linear combinations at maximize
variance
and in terms of these approximations
you know the principal components
well let's suppose you've got some rows
in the matrix or columns in the matrix
that let's think of columns that are
correlated with each other well if one
of those columns have got missing values
you might think you should be able to do
a regression of that column on the other
columns
to compute the missing values
and that's exactly what's going on in
this matrix in this matrix completion
problem using those correlations and i
guess going back to the movie example
you're hoping that
customers respond to similar movies in a
similar way right that's a that's a good
point yeah
you know so even with this sparse number
of uh
entries here
um it's just as rob says what what
you're hoping is that when you know that
there are enough customers who've seen
a movie that you haven't seen
who've got scores for that movie and as
long as those customers have overlapped
with you
in some of the other movies you've made
you can you can find out to what extent
you know you agree with them and and use
those correlations to fill in the
missing values we're exploring both
similarly in customers and similarity in
movies at the same time yes
that's exactly right and and that's of
course due to the wonderful symmetry in
principle components
we can now now give you an algorithm for
for solving this problem we've shown
what we'll do if we can solve it and now
we're going to tell you how to solve it
and it's an extremely simple algorithm
it's an iterative algorithm and it goes
as follows
you start off you could create a
complete data matrix x tilde by filling
in the missing values
with any method say mean imputation
is a good start
and then you're going to repeat these
next three steps until the objective
fails to decrease and this is the
objective it's the same one we had on
the on the previous slide so what you do
is now you've got x tilde is a complete
matrix
you solve the matrix approximation
problem for a complete matrix
and we know we can do that using
principal components so we use the
principal components of x tilde
now what you do is for each missing
entry
you again replace the entries in the
matrix x tilde the missing entries with
the current approximation that you've
just computed remember in the beginning
we just put in the mean values now we've
got a better value to put in and so we
replace those entries and then we see
how well we're doing this
this quantity will
will get smaller each time we do that
then we go back and do it again
so
you keep on filling in with your your
newest guess and then you solve them the
full matrix approximation
and and get new guesses and this will
converge and this quantity of will
bottom out and finally level off and
then you'll declare yourself done
then you'll return the missing entries
in x i j
very simple just iterative principle
components
so we'll use the usa arrest data as an
example
so it's a small matrix this one x has 50
rows they're states and four columns
which are the the different types of of
crime so there's murder assault rape and
then there's the variable urban
population percent of the population
in that state that
lives in in urban areas right
so this data set is complete so we we
artificially made some elements missing
we selected 20 states at random and for
each we selected one of the variables at
random and set its value to n a
so that means out of the 50 states we
now had 20 states where there was one
element missing in one of the variables
all selected at random
and we used m equals one principal
components in the algorithm so we just
use a single principal component to do
the imputation
and what we show in this plot is the
plot of
on the x-axis the original value
and on the y-axis the imputed value
and
since the the variables for which they
was missing were missing
we selected them randomly for these
states
what we show you here is the 20 states
for which are missing values the color
is what variable was missing and we just
show the imputed value
versus the original value
and you can see there's a bit of noise
it doesn't get perfect but there's a
correlation of 0.63 between the original
and imputed values
and what's interesting is
if you used for the complete data if you
use the first principal component
to approximate these same values you'd
get a correlation of 0.73 or 0.72
something like that
you know so the fact that we were
missing
these guys and we were to estimate the
principal component in the presence of
missing values didn't degrade the
solution much
this was a small example only four
variables which is on the low end for
this method to work well and so for this
reason and for this demonstration we
randomly set at most one variable per
state to be missing and we only used m
equals one principal component
in general in order to apply the
algorithm we must select m the number of
principal components
to use for the for imputation because we
don't know in advance what's a good
number going to be
you can imagine if you make it too big
you're going to you may overfit
in in the training and not do well on
the prediction
it turns out there's a way of doing this
automatically using the same method
so what you do is randomly set to n a
some additional elements that were
actually observed
and select m based on how well these
known values are recovered
so this is very close to the validation
set approach that we saw in chapter 5.
so again even though you've got some
elements missing in the matrix you make
a few more missing
and just at random
and then you run your algorithm
but for those that you've artificially
made missing you know they're true value
can so you can see how well you're doing
and you'll get something like a cross
validation curve
so there's a package in r called soft
impute which implements matrix
completion algorithms and can manage
really large problems in fact netflix
scale matrices so if we'd had that in
2005 we would have if we'd had that
we might have had a better shot
yeah
so that's it on
on matrix completion